hunter biden of the president-elect's
son says the u.s attorney in delaware is
investigating his tax record
sources tell cbs news the fbi has been
looking into hunter biden's taxes since
2018.
under justice department policy law
enforcement didn't actively pursue the
case during the weeks before
the presidential election to avoid
politicizing the investigation
ed o'keefe is covering the biden
transition in wilmington delaware ed
what else do we know about this case
well good morning anthony in a statement
released by the president-elect's office
hunter biden said he just learned of the
investigation on tuesday
and that it will find that he acted
quote legally and appropriately
out on the campaign trail the younger
biden was a frequent target of the
president
and his allies
mr biden's youngest son has been the
subject of congressional and media
investigations for work he did in china
and ukraine while his father was vice
president
but no probe has found evidence of
wrongdoing in a statement tuesday mr
biden said he is deeply proud of his son
who has fought through difficult
challenges including the vicious
personal attacks of recent months
only to emerge stronger the announcement
of the investigation came on the day the
president-elect announced his pick for
defense secretary
retired army general lloyd austin who
would be the first
black man to lead the pentagon austin
says he understands concerns from
lawmakers
including several democrats who say he
hasn't been out of the army long enough
and have reservations about granting him
a waiver to serve
i recognize that being a member of the
president's cabinet
requires a different perspective
and unique responsibilities from a
career in uniform
and i intend to keep this at the
forefront of my mind
while mr biden is preparing for his
administration president trump is
focusing on overturning the election
the president joined a lawsuit brought
to the supreme court by the attorney
general of texas that is seeking to
invalidate ballots from four
battleground states won by
president-elect biden
17 republican attorneys general joined
the lawsuit
at a hanukkah party at the white house
president trump praised
the new legal strategy
and the papers were so compelling that
everybody's just joining
legal experts and some republican
officials say that this latest lawsuit
has no chance of succeeding
just as all the other cases to try to
overturn state results
have failed so far anthony and if this
texas case has no chance of success
why are so many attorneys general
joining the suit
well look some of them definitely
believe that there's something up here
and that it deserves to be challenged in
court
it's just the concept of one state
trying to overturn the results of
another state
that many of these legal experts doesn't
believe holds water but look part of
this
for the president clearly is politics
and forgive the holiday metaphor
but to some extent what he's doing here
is he's keeping a list
checking it twice and trying to figure
out which republicans are being naughty
or nice to him
and this pressure extends to other state
officials across the country the atlanta
journal constitution reporting this
morning
that the president called that state's
attorney general on tuesday night asking
him not to rally other gop officials
against this lawsuit brought by texas
georgia of course remains
critical to the biden agenda we've
learned the president-elect plans to
campaign next tuesday in atlanta for the
two democratic senate candidates there
facing a runoff election on january 5th
control of the senate at stake in
georgia ed thank you very much